depuis ce matin nous avons navigué
d'oxymore en paradoxe on rencontre
improbable alors je vous propose de
terminer ce voyage matinal on nous
arrêtons sur un dernier cas de mariage
un peu étrange celui de la démocratie et
du make her movement
c'est à dire pour dire les choses
autrement qu'est ce qui se passe quand
re quand les institutions et les
procédures de la décision publique
soigneusement mise au point affiné
depuis plus de deux siècles rencontre
l'impatience des citoyens leur envie
d'agir et de s'emparer à leur manière
ici et maintenant des problèmes auxquels
ils sont confrontés à ce stade j'imagine
que la question vous paraît un peu
théorique voire spéculative alors je
commence par l'illustré par un exemple
dont nous fêtons aujourd'hui même le
premier anniversaire le 9 mai dernier le
9 mai 2014
on a promulgué en france une loi qui
autorise le don de jours de congé entre
salariés c'est une novation législatif
qui est issu d'un cas réel tout à fait
dramatique
un ouvrier de l'usiné badoit saint
galmier qui avait un enfant âgé d'une
dizaine d'années atteint d'un cancer en
phase terminale
donc pour accompagner son fils dans ces
derniers mois de vie le père a d'abord
essayé de prendre tous les droits à
congés dont il pouvait disposer
évidemment ça a été assez rapidement
épuisés ils ne pouvaient pas non plus de
prendre de congés sans solde parce que
la situation financière de la famille ne
le permettait pas donc un parce que
c'est qu'il passait à ce moment-là les
autres employés de l'usiné sont allés
voir le directeur et lui ont dit mais
nous nous voudrions donner nos jours de
congé à ce collègue
le directeur a accepté 170 jours de
congé ont ainsi été offerts
et puis l'histoire s'est terminée
tragiquement par le décès de l'enfant et
le député de la circonscription voulant
tirer les leçons de cette histoire a
pris l'initiative d'une proposition de
loi pour créer un cadre juridique qui
allaient à l'avenir sécuriserait des
manifestations de générosité de ce type
donc ce que vous voyez là c'est un
exemple tout à fait emblématique d'une
situation nouvelle ou des droits sociaux
c'est à dire un certain aspect du
service public
son nom plus produit par
l'administration où les pouvoirs publics
comme c'était le cas traditionnellement
mais coproduit par des citoyens qui
pourrait être vous et moi qui en
l'occurrence sont des collègues de
travail
cet exemple est particulièrement
spectaculaire mais il est loin d'être le
seul et si nous ouvrons les yeux nous
envoyons des manifestations absolument
dans tous les domaines de l'action
publique autour de nous on voit ça en
matière de sécurité par exemple avec
désormais plus de 3000 ans communes en
france qui ont déployé un dispositif qui
s'appelle voisins vigilants par lequel
les habitants d'un quartier s'organisent
entre eux pour exercer une vigilance
mutuelle est donc un premier niveau de
sécurité
évidemment pour les cas plus grave c'est
la police ou la gendarmerie on voit ça
dans l'éducation alors je prendrai
peut-être un exemple plus exotique pour
nous faire voyager c'est une école
brésilienne qui ait résolu une manière
assez créative le problème typique des
professeurs de langues qui et comment je
fais pour donner à mes élèves la
possibilité de pratiquer la langue et
donc de s'exercer
quand j'ai trente 30 personnes pendant
une heure donc le temps d'expliquer la
grammaire et vocabulaire il n'y a plus
de temps donc est ce qu'elle a fait
cette école elle a passé un partenariat
avec une maison de retraite des environs
de chicago et vous avez en binôme des
retraités américains et des jeunes
élèves brésilien qui parle par skype qui
font des heures de conversation ce qui
permet aux jeunes élèves de pratiquer
l'anglais est quand même bien le but
sans écarter le professeur qui supervise
ces conversations lors d'un un script
mais ce que vous voyez c'est que le
service d'enseignement est désormais co
produit par un professeur brésilien et
des volontaires américains
un dernier exemple pour finir et et me
raccrocher à l'actualité
vous avez sans doute vu qu'il ya eu ce
séisme au népal récemment eh bien on a
vu cette fois ci comme dans tous les cas
de catastrophe naturelle depuis
désormais quelques années des milliers
de volontaires immédiatement en quelques
heures se mobiliser pour établir une
cartographie fiable des zones de
désastre c'est à dire sous l'égide
d'organisations comme openstreetmap
fundation par exemple ils vont prendre
des photos satellites des fonds de
cartes est dire si tel pont est toujours
debout tel route est toujours praticable
en les reportant sur une carte afin que
les secours puissent être opérationnels
donc tous ces exemples et je pourrais en
ajouter bien d'autres vous donne un
petit peu l'idée de ce que c'est ce
phénomène qu'on voit apparaître qui est
finalement l'implication des citoyens
dans la production du service public
alors vous me diriez une collection
d'exemple ça ne fait pas forcément une
tendance c'est à dire un nuage de points
ça ne fait pas forcément système au cas
particulier on a de bonnes raisons de
penser que oui c'est à dire que c'est un
mouvement qui est en train de se
dessiner
parce que quand on analyse
l'environnement on voit qu'il y à deux
facteurs extrêmement puissant qui
poussent en ce sens le premier facteur
c'est que l'état alors quand je dis
l'état comprenait les pouvoirs publics
au sens large
ça peut être des collectivités
territoriales se pète des hôpitaux
peut-être la sécurité sociale enfin
disons les pouvoirs publics ont tout
simplement besoin de nous besoin de
notre aide en tant que citoyen pour
accomplir leur mission
aujourd'hui bien plus qu'hier ils en ont
besoin pour des raisons financières
parce que la contrainte budgétaire est
telle qu'ils ne peuvent pas juste
dépenser davantage pour améliorer le
service ou tout simplement le maintenir
ils en ont besoin pour des raisons
techniques parce que les problèmes
auxquels nous sommes confrontés
aujourd'hui ont changé de nature et que
ça n'est plus seulement l'intervention
de fonctionnaires ou la distribution de
subventions qui va les résoudre c'est à
dire que si votre problème par exemple
en matière de santé est passée du
traitement des pathologies aiguës au
traitement des maladies chroniques
alors ce n'est pas le médecin qui va
faire la différence en tout cas elle pas
lui tout seul c'est l'hygiène de vie de
la personne à son domicile
les la présence de son entourage si
notre problème
et la récupération des enfants risque de
décrochage scolaire ça n'est pas le
professeur devant la classe qui va
résoudre l'ensemble du problème c'est là
encore une question de présence d'
accompagnement par un la famille si
c'est possible mais sinon par des grands
frères des mentors ce que vous voulez si
notre problème c'est la lutte contre le
racisme et les discriminations il
suffira pas de quelques fonctionnaires
dans un bureau ou de quelques règles
c'est chacun d'entre nous qui doit
modifier son comportement
donc la nature des problèmes qui a
changé plus la contrainte financière
fait que l'état besoin de nous de notre
côté nous la société nous avons changé
aussi
est ce qu'on voit c'est des citoyens
beaucoup plus impatients d'agir et de
s'emparer des problèmes et si les
citoyens ont envie d'agir
il n'y aurait rien de plus dangereux
pour l'état que de faire semblant de
l'ignorer parce qu'à ce moment là
cette envie d'agir va s'exprimer en
dehors de tout cadre et peut conduire à
des débordements
là encore j'imagine qu'un petit exemple
vaudra mieux qu'une longue explication
pensait ce qui s'est passé en janvier
après les attentats contre charlie hebdo
contre l'hyper cacher un groupe de
hackers des anonymous s'est mis à
attaquer des sites internet qui étaient
réputés propager de la propagande
jihadiste
c'est finalement plutôt sympathique en
premier abord que des citoyens se
mobilisent pour une noble cause
le seul problème c'est que qui a décidé
que tel site était effectivement
jihadistes il ya un problème de de
droits à la défense si vous voulez et
deuxièmement plus plus facilement
visible dès le lendemain les cyber
jihadistes ont répliqué par des milliers
d' attaques sur des sites publics en
france donc on est dans un engrenage de
loi de la jungle
mais au moins on donc on voit bien ses
forces qui poussent l'état qui a besoin
nous nous qui avons envie d'agir et
c'est pourquoi je pense qu'on a affaire
à une véritable tendance alors si c'est
le cas prenons le au sérieux et
demandons-nous quelles conséquences cela
a des conséquences pratiques bien sûr
c'est à dire il faut que
l'administration revoit ses procédures
son organisation je laisse la de côté ce
n'est pas le propos du jour et ce à des
conséquences politiques extrêmement
importante qui est ce sur quoi je
voudrais m'appesantir ni plus ni moins
en réalité qu'une modification assez
substantielle du contrat social entre
les citoyens et l'autorité publique
alors pour expliquer ça je suis obligée
d'entrer un peu plus dans le détail pour
l'instant j'ai fait comme si tous ces
phénomènes d'implication des citoyens
dans la production du service public
étaient plus ou moins similaires en
réalité ils sont de sorte à ces
différentes pour reprendre le jargon des
sociologues les arbres relève de ce
qu'on appelle la réciprocité simple et
d'autre de la réciprocité élargi la
réciprocité simple c'est donnant donnant
c'est à dire moi service public
je vais demander à vous citoyens de
faire votre parti du travail si vous
voulez recevoir le service
donc vous devez triez vos déchets
recyclables si vous voulez que vos
poubelles soit enlevée devant chez vous
vous devez passer par votre médecin
référent si vous allez consulter un
spécialiste
sinon vous ne serez pas correctement
remboursé si vous êtes australien et que
le projet de loi actuel en discussion la
bave à son terme
si vous avez des enfants vous ne
recevrez vos allocations familiales que
si vous les faites vacciner
le slogan c'est pas de piqûre pas
d'argent comme ça c'est clair
donc la réciprocité simple j'ai essayé
de vous en donner une idée si ça
fonctionne c'est simple ça revient à
dire la puissance publique essaie
d'optimiser l'efficacité de son action
en nous demandant à nous d'en faire une
partie
c'est à dire c'est un mouvement vers la
droite de ce texte que vous voyez
représenté ici partant d'une situation
où finalement le service public était si
ce n'est entièrement universel du moins
très largement accessible en passant par
une étape intermédiaire où il est devenu
sous condition qu'ils sous conditions de
ressources de statut familial de
handicap de ce que vous voulez
vers maintenant une situation où il sous
condition de comportement donc vous
vacciner vos enfants vous triez vos
déchets etc
parce que bien sûr si vous ne vacciner
pas vos enfants alors la vaccination n'a
plus aucun sens puisque l'ensemble de la
population
le fasse donc c'est un principe
d'efficacité ça c'est une chose
maintenant nous avons autre chose comme
je l'indiqué la réciprocité élargi ça
c'est tout à fait différent la
réciprocité élargie c'est quand
quelqu'un donne non pas dans l'espoir
d'en avoir à un retour mais pour le bien
de la collectivité
c'est à dire ce sont mes retraités
américains qui acceptent de passer du
temps
à aider les brésiliens et les étudiants
brésiliens apprendre l'anglais
ce sont mes milliers de volontaires qui
passent leurs nuits à cartographier les
ruines de katmandou pour aider les
secours
c'est les ouvriers de l'usiné badoit qui
donne un jour de congé pour leurs
collègues
ça c'est de la réciprocité élargie et
donc finalement ça consiste à passer du
chacun pour soi est entre parenthèses
l'administration pour tous ah fat un
pour tous enfin idéalement en termes
plus avant ça consiste à passer d'une
notion du bien public à une notion du
bien commun et la différence c'est que
le bien public
c'est l'idée que l'intérêt général nous
l'avons confié de manière exclusive à
l'administration à qui nous avons
délégué tous nos pouvoirs sous
l'autorité d'élus politiques à qui nous
avons donné mandat de nous représenter
donc voilà une fois que nous avons voté
et payer nos impôts c'est fini nous
n'avons plus à nous en occuper le bien
commun en revanche c'est l'idée que
l'intérêt général ne va exister
réellement que si nous nous en occupons
personnellement au quotidien tous les
jours
ne serait ce que parce qu'il comporte
des aspects immatériels qui ne se
délègue pas la confiance le lien social
tous ces aspects matériels qui font
qu'une société tourne alors muni cette
grille de lecture je reviens à mon nuage
de points et il me semble que c'est
manon plus claire de dieu discerner ce
qui se passe pour moi ce qui se passe
c'est ce que j'essaie de représenter sur
ce graphique
nous sommes ici dans une situation dans
le grave dans le carré numéro un où vous
avez d'un côté la puissance publique qui
est en train de cheminer sur un axe
horizontal
c'est à dire le long d'une réciprocité
simple en se disant bon il ya une
demande sociale immense j'ai des moyens
limités il faut que je trouve un moyen
de gérer la pénurie et pour cela
finalement de mettre des conditions à la
délivrance du service public de demander
au citoyen de faire leur partie du
chemin donc l'état se déplace
latéralement vers la droite de ce
graphique mais pendant ce temps là les
citoyens eux ils font tout à fait autre
chose
ils sont en train de se déplacer vers le
haut faire ce que j'ai dénommé ici open
bidouille parce que je trouve que c'est
un nom assez sympathique et qui dit bien
ce que ça veut dire c'est le
réel d'une association qui promeut ce
genre d'idée c'est à dire bah le service
public n'est plus si facilement
accessible qu autrefois donc on va se
débrouiller par nous mêmes c'est à dire
bon il le quartier de ma ville n'est pas
suffisamment desservi en transports
publics et bien ce pas grave je vais
faire du covoiturage il n'y a plus de
place dans la crèche municipale et bien
j'aime ce groupe et avec d'autres
familles on fera une garde d'enfant
partager ça c'est open bidouille typique
est ce que on peut durer longtemps avec
un des dirigeants politiques
administratifs qui partent dans un sens
et des citoyens qui part dans un autre
sens alors il ya évidemment un scénario
négatif c'est que les mouvements
contraires des uns et des autres
aboutissent en fait à ce qu'on reste
rouyn c'est dans la case numéro un c'est
un scénario très défavorable parce que
c'est une paupérisation sur pied du
service public mais comme nous sommes
c'est ed nous sommes optimistes et
résolu n'est ce pas delphine donc je
vais plutôt vous parler de de la vision
plus optimiste des scénarios qui sont
devant nous nous sommes une démocratie
donc normalement c'est quand même le
gouvernement qui s'ajuste aux
aspirations des citoyens n'est pas l'
inverse donc finalement l'enjeu qui est
devant nous c'est comment nous nous
aidons la sphère publique
l'administration et les ai dû accomplir
leur métamorphose du cadran 2 vers le
cadran 4 alors on peut le faire pour
l'administration sont des dispositions
hôtel qui commence à être bien conçu de
transformer l'organisation plate forme
ça s'appelle techniquement sur l'aspect
politique qui est peut-être plus ce qui
est dans vos centres d'intérêt ici il
suffit de regarder de demander aux
anthropologues du don et du contre don
de nous donner la clé est la clé c'est
ceci lorsque des gens s'impliquent dans
un système de réciprocité élargi
lorsqu'il donne comme sa part pour le
bénéfice de la communauté
ça n'est pas par acte de générosité
envers une personne en particulier
ça n'est pas non plus par acte de
générosité envers l'ensemble des
personnes constituant la collectivité
c'est en raison de l'attachement à une
entité beaucoup plus abstraite et
symbolique qu'on appelle le tiers qui en
fait notre sentiment d'existence
partager ce qui nous tient ensemble
alors sans se rappellera peut-être à
certains d'entre vous la définition
pernès trône en donner d'une main
nation c'est un rêve d'avenir partager
donc je reviens mais politique
leur rôle pour passer du cac 32 et du
cadran 4 c'est d'exercer leur leadership
d'une manière tout à fait nouvelle il ne
consiste pas à prendre mille et une
décision petites et grandes en notre nom
puisque nous leur en avons donné mandat
mais inspiré chacun d'entre nous à agir
et pour cela à faire exister si
puissamment un rêve d'avenir partagé que
chacun d'entre nous voudra y trouver sa
place et n'aura qu'une envie c'est d'y
contribuer voilà merci de votre
attention